avant l'été 2010
qu'est ce que personne dans la petite
ville tranquille de machault luis figo
ne connaissait enbridge
allez les gars 80 % des gens d'ici moss
ne savais pas qu'il y avait un pipeline
j'ignorais complètement qu'il
transportait du pétrole des sables
bitumineux
enbridge possède le réseau de pikine le
plus étendu au monde 26 mille kilomètres
de conduite qui s'étendent jusqu'au
québec resam aussi comme le fait pas
personne ne s'y intéressait le 25
juillet 2010 les gens de man show où tu
appris son existence de la firme manière
qui soit
la conduite numéro 6 a laissé échapper
près de trois millions et demi de litres
de pétrole brut dans l'environnement
l'accident a révélé des lacunes
insoupçonnée dans la sécurité et
l'entretien du pipeline bref ils ont
développé une culture de déviance et
c'est devenu la norme d'endroits où un
tel accident pourrait t'il se produire
ici au québec ça pourrait produire
n'importe où